What's up?
[Silence]
You want to be shame.
I'm the one.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allham.
[Silence]
The fifth invalidator of that the author
mentions
and he only mentions Five
is
aklam.
[Silence]
In surah
narrates that the messenger of Allah
said
make wudoo after eating the meat of
camels.
and do not make wool after eating the
meat of sheep or goats.
Now
the issue of
making woo
from that which goes into the body. This
is
one of the only instances
or the only instance
in which
we are commanded to make wubul
from something that goes into the body
rather than coming out.
We mentioned that the essence of what
breaks a person's woo
the the essential
thing that breaks a person's will that
we can really look at the pattern
not just in but also in
it is
not just from that which comes out of
the body but specifically
that which comes out of the private
parts.
This is really the pattern that you see
across the board.
So for instance
in
from janaba,
what is janaba? Janaba is the expulsion
of
sexual secretions
at climax.
This is something that is expelled from
the body that takes a person into a
major state of hadith.
Likewise,
a female who is
menrating
or in postpartum bleeding, it is from
that which is coming from the womb
or woo which is from that which comes
out of a sebullet and even
sleep
and even
intoxication
or
loss of consciousness
follows
the first two which is what comes out of
the private parts. This is a pattern.
Start to see a pattern here.
And so
making wool from that which goes into
the body,
that which goes into the body. This is
the only instance we truly have of this.
And for this reason, it's very curious.
And for this reason, the majority of the
fukah
view this as being mans
as being something that was abregated.
Because when we look at the of Abu Bakr
and Omar and Ali and all four of these,
they all agreed
during their their respective
that
this is abregated.
And for this reason you'll find
the madab of Abihanifa
Shafir
and Malik
all agree that this is abregated and
this is considered one of the
im Ahmed.
However,
I'm mentioning this for an important
reason. What is that reason?
Does
the prophet's narrations his words
sallallam
do they need
any med or any majority of people to
validate them?
If
the messenger of Allah says something
and the majority of humanity
does not adopt that which he has
said. Does this lesson in its authority
in any way? Let me reframe it.
We have
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam's words
and all of the scholars of the earth
adopt it. Does that make his words
stronger?
No.
We have his words and all of the earth's
scholars do not adopt it. Does that make
it weaker? No.
But this is not the only variable that
goes into the
of the
and I mention this because
this is for us. We all have the best of
thoughts of our scholars and imams that
all of them have the primary
goal of adhering to the sunnah,
identifying it and then adhering to it.
All of them.
That is where they all agree. And this
is why the Muslim and the scholars of
Sunnah one of their descriptions is they
do not differ even they do not they
do not separate even when they differ.
a narration this
we see that the prophet sallallah.aii
am very clearly, very plainly says,
"Make
after eating the meat of camels." Could
not be more clear. And all of the
scholars agree on this. Where they
disagree is whether this is a standing
command or whether he had later
abregated it.
How common is it for us to eat camel
meat? When's the last time you ate camel
meat?
[Arabic recitation]
never eaten camel meat.
Right. And I think that the majority of
us in America probably have never eaten
camel meat. And we may go the majority
of our lives without eating it. However,
when's the last time you ate chicken?
[Arabic recitation]
could probably say yesterday.
Now, if we lived during the time of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam,
it would be the opposite of what you
just said. Your experience would be
exactly the opposite.
Meaning as common as chicken is for us,
camel meat is for them and vice versa.
Chickens would actually be rather rare.
And the the narrations about chickens
are actually very very rare.
Those were the staples of their
environment.
And so
when the scholars look at a narration
this, they don't just take into
consider to consideration the narration
itself, but largely the environment.
This is this is something that is so
common
that it would be common knowledge
amongst the average Muslim. The average
Muslim
just like
the average Muslim knows
that
comes before and that there's two
sides and one
and that to make woo you start with the
face and then the arms and then it this
would be for them because camel meat is
part of their constant diet.
And so it becomes something akin to
the earlier mentions of the
invalidators of wudoo. And if we
understand that about the environment
then it makes something Abu Bakr
and Omar and Ali all of them agreeing
that camel meat does not break a
person's wudoo that really makes that
very curious now doesn't it that raises
it it it's now not just an abstract
oneoff curiosity this is very
interesting interesting because this
means that not only they personally but
in their
and this is why even in the med of Im
Ahmed
there are two opinions
there's actually more than two but for
our intents and purposes we'll mention
two and that is
When we have across the board major
companions
who were there from the beginning of
Islam to the end and then later became
the leaders of the Muslim and in charge
of passing on the religion to the next
generation.
When we have them agreeing on something
as common knowledge, this
elevates a one-off curiosity and makes
it a part of the known culture.
And so for this reason,
we have the narration.
However, there are other narrations and
other issues
that are at play with such a thing.
There is no Im Abu Hanifh or Im Malik or
Im
says yes this is the narration I concede
to that but I think this doesn't happen
with these m this happened way later in
the latter years of this ummah when
innovation came into Islam this is not
the m of these imams I think and the
narration they do not clash In these
however there's more at play their
intention is never to disobey the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam for
a scholar, for a student of knowledge,
for a person of knowledge, it is not
enough
just to learn a med. But for the vast
majority of the Muslim, of course, it is
enough. That is what is expected is that
the Muslim listen to their scholars and
that they obey their scholars. Is
obedience of the scholars binding or
optional?
Of course, it's binding.
It's binding by the Quran and it's
binding by the Sunnah. This is not
optional.
Now, obeying a scholar's opinion, that's
a different issue. But the obedience of
scholars in absence of knowledge is
absolutely binding.
And so for our intents and purposes,
if you were to ever eat camel meat,
maybe once in your life, go ahead and
make wudoo.
And they all agree that making wudoo
after eating camel meat is still what
preferred. They only differ on whether
it's an obligation or not, which is why
the author mentions it.
Subhanahu wa'tala.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.